as a cast going it's going now here's my
question for you are you ready for next
year to be seeing some black lightning
cosplay out there you see them on
elevator already like you just covered
the entire elevator so we got to go a
step up from this yes crest I love that
you're repping for the GC family right
now thank you
gives you a black lightning show
superheroes are seriously having a
moment right now but what I'm so excited
about is that black lightning is totally
different than all those other
superheroes right now for the fans out
there who don't know the comments give
us the rundown okay
aka Black Lightning was a hero nine
years prior there's a teacher since then
he's become principal of Garfield High
as a retired force family and the family
gets it some danger so he comes out of
retirement I'm so excited because this
is the first black superhero on
broadcast television first like all
black super family that we're gonna be
seeing right now what does that mean to
you it's amazing it's yeah it's
inspiring it's great that we are at that
place you know in the world to be able
to do that and people can accept it yeah
and think that it's great and relate to
it so we're honored yeah and I think
with Black Lightning our our goal is
just to serve hope that we can make a
change within our country and within our
communities and that's who the Lightning
is yeah should we give a little rundown
the fans on all of our characters out
there older sister I'm Jefferson
Pierce's oldest order and this appears
AKA thunder and thunder is a force of
her own she is definitely interested in
following her father's footsteps but she
wants to however create her own path and
how only and she fights for what's right
and if she believes in it she's gonna go
hard for it and yeah that's who Thunder
is he's very powerful she's fearless and
smart Jennifer Pierce the youngest
daughter of Jefferson piers and in the
beginning she's just trying to find
herself she's a teenager she's 16 years
old getting into a little bit of trouble
which is part of the reason why I could
go to MIT and I'm saving our lives
but it's interesting because you get to
see her arc and you get to see her
actually develop her powers for the
first time on the show and see what she
handles right and what things she miss
handles a lot of that stuff so it's
interesting and I am Christine i play
Lynn Pierce okay former mrs. Black
Lightning two incredible young women who
are about to you know go out into the
world and use their powers hopefully for
good and I'm probably you know the
nurturer and the one that probably
grounds them the most and really just
holds them together is that I am
co-creator and executive producer of the
show and just enjoying writing these
tales for them Salim Akil my superpower
is show running
[Applause]
yeah I'll make it for you guys I won't
wear next year I'm sure you guys have
already got this in the works in the
first season but what I'm curious to see
is any boys out there trying to date
these to close the show yeah this is
this is really cool because you know our
goal is to be authentic to what we we
know black lightning to be in the comic
book so we shall see some interest in
things don't always end our relationship
seriously one of the most diverse shows
oh my gosh what do you want to tell the
fans out there before they tune in what
should they know before they press play
well they should know they're gonna have
a damn good time yeah much as it is
uniquely a celebrant celebration a
family a celebration of black culture it
is a it is a story for all of us because
we do have to figure out what is our own
superpower and accept who we are and
it's not always gonna be easy to get out
there and be a hero but I mean through
the example of these characters I think
people want to
so as of right now Black Lightning is
not necessarily in the arrowverse not
really necessarily in the same universe
which I'm really excited about because I
want you guys to be able to have that
time to shine on your own and really
establish yourself but you know
Supergirl originally wasn't in the air
over as well so in season two
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]